good evening ladies and gentlemen i'd
just like to
open this evening with a tribute to
sir david amis and i will introduce you
to
reverend richard iles who will be
leading the service thank you
good evening ladies and gentlemen
we gathered here this evening at this
time
to
remember
the tragic death
of sir david amos
and a moment of prayer
before we lead
a moment of silence
for god in the busyness and
the chaotic nature of our lives
we come this moment
at this time
to remember before god
those that have been lost
in tragic circumstances
and as we gather to do business later
may we spend a few moments in
remembering
sir david amos
and all the good that he did for our
community
in this area
and
nationally
and we ask these things in the name of
jesus christ
our savior
amen amen
i think it would be appropriate if we
stand
three minutes
please be seated
we're now going to listen
to a number
of tributes
and i'm going to call upon
chairman of the council councillor mrs
julie good
it is with great sadness
that we pay tribute to the memory of sir
david amis
david was one of the kindest and
compassionate politicians
who touched the lives
of so many
during his extensive public service
he had the ability to listen to people
and make them feel valued
he wasn't afraid to challenge what he
believed in to make a difference
on occasion
david lent me his personal support as he
in common with me
was passionate about supporting our nhs
i recall one occasion when i had sailed
down the hospital tower at south end
hospital to raise funds
for the renal unit
he went out of his way to take the time
to listen to why this was so important
to me
more recently
david celebrated the nhs birthday at an
event held at saxon hall earlier this
year
followed
an exceedingly challenging period for
everyone the fact that he commemorated
the nhs event in the company of local
constituents
was greatly appreciated
the outpouring of love
in the aftermath of the tragic event
resulting in the loss of sir david
is testament to the wonderful man he was
and what he meant to our local community
as a council i hope these overwhelming
tributes may bring small comfort to sir
david's family and my sincere heartfelt
condolences go to david's family and
loved ones
at this most devastating time of their
lives god bless them all
i'm now going to call
on
the leader of the council councillor
simon wooten
who will pay tribute to sir david banks
thank you
[Music]
no decent person could help but to feel
appalled and shocked at the violent and
tragic manner in which sir david amis
was murdered on friday the 15th of
october
since then
we have heard so many tributes and kind
words said about him
a huge number of people will have known
sir david from a variety of perspectives
i had met him on many occasions
the latest at a dinner just a few weeks
before he died where he was the guest
speaker
we sat near each other
i was asked and it was my privilege to
give the vote of thanks following his
excellent speech
indeed i was due to be at another dinner
with him on the evening of the day he
died
what can i add that hasn't already been
said in the very kind tributes to sir
david over these past few weeks
probably nothing
he was a kind and caring man
who saw his duty
as an mp to work hard for his residents
and to do the best for the community he
represented
so well in order to make it a better
place in which to live
he was engaging and passionate about
things he believed in
he had a good sense of humor
he was deeply religious
he loved and cared about his family who
our thoughts and sympathies are
particularly with at this sad and
difficult time
he was i believe a role mod model to us
all
and was an example about how to live
life to the full
so david you will be hugely missed in so
many ways and from a variety of
perspectives
rest in peace
thank you chairman
i now call
upon the deputy leader of the council
councillor sheryl rowe to pay a tribute
to sedate davis
thank you
sir david was a great friend to many of
us
our thoughts and prayers are with sir
david's family as we mourn for a man who
gave his life to the people of south end
so david's legacy of creating a city is
to be remembered as a brilliant
achievement
and his devote devotion to his community
over 40 years is a testament to his
strength of character and caring nature
he will be missed dearly and we pray he
rests in peace
would any other members like to make a
tribute
thank you chairman
i've known david amos for as long as
i've been a
district councillor for 17 years
and there's two
things i remember him most on
once when i was chairman of this council
he invited me to a
centenary um
function
where his mother was supposed to be
invited
and it was all for the elderly residents
at his particular home
we had a lovely a lovely party
and i spoke to one of the residents
there and the president said to me
we don't have any tea dances now do we
and i said well we can do
and i asked him to dance
and david amos came up to me afterwards
and said to me
i knew it'd be you i knew it'd be you to
get up and ask the elderly residents to
dance
that was the first thing i always
remember with david the second one
i was down at b and q one day with my
late partner
and who was walking up and down the
aisles was david amos hello he said what
are you doing down here i said oh we're
just pottering about what you don't down
here
well i'm having to take photographs of
lights because my wife wants a new light
in the house
and we stood there and laughed and joked
about certain things and there's two
memorable things i will always remember
about david
thank you chairman
um
thank you
i first met sir david
when my mother's friend introduced us in
the late 80s
when he was mp for basildon
we had much in common
born in the east end
with clara and blue running through our
veins
and a love of pugs
clara and blue is west ham for those who
don't know
he was a committed politician
working hard for basildon
and showed passion and compassion
for all
he was a man of the people
people of all political colors respected
him
always working
answered all letters and phone calls
he was a dedicated to his work
and a true gentleman
i would see david occasionally at that
time
and he always remembered my name
then in 1997
he became mp for southend
our children then went to the same
school
and became friends
as young children do they had sleepovers
and stayed at each other's houses
so i got to know him more
as a family man and a friend
friday's sleepovers were better for them
as on a sunday his girls would often
have to get up to go to church
and after a night of not sleeping that
was not very good
they always had fun
on one occasion
when staying with david and julia
david got locked in the study overnight
we never found out who was the
ringleader
but he took it in goodsport
as he always did
locking up a night of the realm
david was a wonderful speaker
both formerly in the house of commons
and informally at private private
dinners and events
he was eloquent
clear and persuasive
with his passion on subjects
showing through
informally he was amusing
interesting
and sometimes a little cheeky
leaving
us all
wanting to hear more
the last occasion i saw him
was just after his daughter got married
and just before my youngest daughter's
wedding
this september
we discuss weddings speeches
and where have the years gone
but how happy we were
that our children were happy and settled
david loved his family
he loved his city
he loved animals
and he was a true patriot
he worked hard for each and every one
valuing all equally
he had many causes
one was animal welfare
speaking about tethering horses
and mules
and crating hens and cruelty to pigs
and he always cared about dogs
he loved
all living creatures
his last words to me were
see you soon
i wish
god bless david
rest in peace
condolences to julia and the family
thank you
now we'll have councillor steptoe
i first met david uh when i was chairman
of the carnival association in south end
and it was my task to get both mps and
the mayor of south end
doing things that are well out of their
comfort zone
especially for the carnival
and on one occasion it was the
carnival's 100th anniversary
and we had a considerable number of the
ex-carnival queens came
along we hired a
single decker
south end transport bus from the canbu
candy bus museum
and
for the carnival queens to ride along on
the seafront in the carnival
now david came up to me and said what
job have you got for me david
and i said it's great job david
you're in charge of all the old queens
you never quite forgave me for saying
that
but on another occasion
um he asked me to uh do some canvassing
with him
in one of my old cars
little morris eight and it's eight
because it's an eight horsepower
modern car is a couple of hundred
and
i arrived at south end airport to pick
up his passenger
and he was ann whitaker
so there's myself
david
and whitaker and two of his kids
in my little aunt morris eight
and as we're driving around lee i
suddenly realized oh we're heading for
lee hill
and i commented well we might just have
to get out and push
david was chuckling away next to me but
i did get these strange comments coming
from behind me from young anne
and some years later i bumped into anne
and another do
and she really did remember the occasion
that she nearly had to get out and push
tomorrow's 8 with david
david you will be missed
it was great fun and always
good for life
god bless you
councillor
smith
thank you
um
like many others i met david at a
variety of occasions
uh political and social
and when i when i see that picture and
and i've seen the pictures of it
recently
it's it's difficult to imagine what has
happened you just imagine him to become
bounding through the door with that
happy cheerful voice
that he he always had
and i i i very much liked the the
comment that uh
was made shortly after the terrible
event
where he was described while he was
still alive commonly known as the late
david amis as i think we all know his
timekeeping was uh
something to be desired to say to say
the least
but over the years
seeing him as
a a politician in action and seeing the
craft that he could display
of talking to everyone remembering
everyone making everyone feel special he
felt quite privileged to to be in his
presence
it was amazing how he managed to get to
so many places to support so many things
to see so many people
he he
he's gone too soon but by goodness
didn't he do a good job while he was
here
thank you
reverend
there are so many ways in which we can
remember
sir david
very personal
very humorous
filled with intellect
he was a man of incredible integrity
he would talk to anyone
of any faith
or no faith
he was interested
and he would sit or stand and listen and
we have heard so many different ways
i met david on one occasion
where he invited me to go round the
houses of parliament
and as we were wondering he was telling
us all the little snippets and all of
the the interesting fun facts about
the houses of parliament
and he was someone who would make light
but also make serious
and i wonder
if i could
finish by just reminding us
that
we are
left behind
and
we have memories
in so many different ways whether that
is of personal
or political
but the one thing that we need to carry
on for him
is to continue to do what he would love
and see
the city that he has chosen
to be transformed into a a great city
we are not in that city
as councillors
but we are representatives and perhaps
one lesson that we need to learn is to
follow in with in his footsteps by being
people
of integrity
come what may
thank you
thank you
we will now take a short break
and reconvene at 7 30.